hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to crash world now crash
world is a game where you're a pizza
delivery man sorry yes right on to the
hospital it's a game where you're a
pizza delivery guy and you're trying to
make every possible delivery possible
fire X fing what does that even mean
alright anyway so there's it you'd love
a pic okay you know what I'm just gonna
go for it
I've never played in today hi how's it
going I'm gonna call you Oh Uncle Bing
oh is that Bing obliged dad Blair and
uncle big player can I change my name
oh god change name okay ah you're so
into me okay although I okay all this
crashing aside and explode there's a
tire
oh there's screaming though oh god can
you stop just leave it alone he's
already dead the thing that tree have
sent alright good thing that tree of
censorship it's right there in the way
so nobody knows okay I'm gonna call
myself blasty where did I go blasts team
explodey that's me baby hi player
goddamnit my name is blasts team
exploding just call me blasts t come on
please I'm begging you call me blast e
player and uncle Bing open up a pizza
place get rid of hotdog vendors but your
turf in this endless delivery run why is
it endless I'm gonna look at this button
cuz weird and questionable and I like
weird there's nothing oh god what did it
do I'm sorry if I blew anybody up I'm
gonna change my ride o fastest pizza car
in hip history pepperoni powered I don't
believe that I think you're lying
suspicious limo this car looks rather
suspicious is it cuz there's people
banging in it or there's dead bodies in
it or there's dead bodies in the pizzo
or uncle ping actually isn't my uncle
Stang pizza delivery just got seriously
I thought you just said excuse my beauty
I thought you just said that that was
the fastest pizza delivery truck all
right whatever hat
that no no hat you going naked baby oh
not a hat for me I have for the car well
of course I should have no that's a
human Jesus friend at don't go funniest
thing I've seen all day
oh well All Right see ya well then okay
all right I guess beer keg never leave
home without your beer keg yeah I mean
that's my usual policy cuz at any moment
I could take a drink while I'm driving
and die both from the alcohol and from
the driving and drunk ladder act going
up gravestone at the land of the dead
extra so my car can vape I understand I
see what you're doing here alright gas
at its gas bottles on your head press
space to activate reenact that episode
of mythbusters' friend hat dude friend
how many friends can i spawner Oh God
never ending friends it's an avalanche
of chairs this is the greatest thing
I've ever seen in my life by the way I
don't know if you guys knew but this is
the greatest thing I've ever seen in my
life alright well I gotta go I gotta I
gotta go with the friend hat but I just
can't not go with the friend hat I have
to right here's B my god actually this
game isn't just about putting my friend
on my car I got to deliver some pizza
we're open for business and we made all
these pizzas but these hot dog vendors
are killing us so let's kill them trash
them and I'm going up going God okay see
you uncle Bing no mercy sure thing okay
alright then I'm not pressing a button
I guess alright let's take it nice and
easy I got my what up home
how it do let's take him nice and easy I
got a friend on my car shoot me I
haven't done anything sir
I I did nothing I did nothing I had
nothing to do with that
I had nothing my money long hey darling
I am doing nothing I just want to say I
got a friend on my hat and that's it I'm
not resisting I am complying sir
ma'am all right here we go hold on
friend get these nutritious apples cuz
that's what's important there wreck the
hot dog guy
why I'd I tried you know I actually
tried but my instinct was just like I
shouldn't Merc what is happening to that
dog are you shooting me okay now it's
just so that was just self-defense at
that point oh I am so sorry ah sorry oh
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah I am so sorry
okay that's a dent I think I went for a
wrench which helped apparently all right
man this game this game is fun but it
runs like a potato Wow wreck you hotdog
man hello sir
don't mind me why is everyone so angry
I'm just trying to deliver pizza well
actually I'm not but you know happy god
this this game has like two frames a
second what is going on boy
okay all right then yeah I got ya yeah
yeah let me change some settings the
graphical fidelity is just too extreme
hello hotdog man it's good babe sorry
okay all right I'm gonna actually try to
play this game well now I mean by well I
mean I'm I'm gonna go around town and
murder hot dog vendors for some reason
sorry excuse me what up homes all right
good iron me all right
yiii where my friend go my friend oh not
worth it I'm sorry
you'll be back your back is halfway
across the city
that's good joke alright God is running
late potato again
I hope that when I'm meeting my imminent
demise I have enough wherewithal to say
shout at the top of my lungs fool I'm
gonna I'm dead aren't I well then scores
yeah let's see how I did woo
oh that's why it was saving replays Oh
woo you see me you should see me you
practically crashed through my window to
see be so funny hey I gotta go get my
friend I gotta go get my friend before I
do any of this profile no not that not
that okay play-doh get my friend there
is Darius that's mobile while please
hotdogs fondos are calling me truce them
and woot shoot for the coops poop in the
boots of couch cushions and smoosh I'm
going I'm a smash Uncle Bing don't worry
about me I'll worry about me
oh right the hot guard oh good good good
Oh
come get some iron got some I didn't
like it Oh repair don't hit me don't hit
me I'm a ticking time bomb oh well I'm
probably gonna die how can i I'm gonna
I'm gonna make this conflagration the
most epically damaging possible ah good
yes there comes my no frames flap thank
you sorry I really I'm not sorry at all
actually in fact of the matter is that
[Music]
yeah I better get these apples fix up my
car
excuse me sir a nice striped shirt I
loved you in undertale hey gray well
doesn't help when I get the repair thing
and then immediately hit something else
sorry nice mohawk I got no frames
I got no frames Oh God wrench
well pit wolf that wrench was completely
negated yeah I'm not sorry at all
[Music]
[Laughter]
where's my stripper it's the fire truck
guy like the fire truck got there too
late he's a friend what ain't friend you
know I forget I was saying anything
friend who's just look shut up mark God
Adam you proud of me Uncle Bing I'm
murdered
you're out of me uncle Bing all right
sorry sorry my friend is a very
apologetic corner my poor friend
ah hey hope you're insured mr. policeman
huh by the way this game is difficult
all right good ah no a wrench II you
know what forget it I can't even wait I
gotta get this guy never mind I did
neither of
things that I wanted to do please you
want pizzas no Juke yuck
I'm dead Duke you're riding to death
Jesus okay buy it please officer taking
the hot air balloon Express up to heaven
anyway that's enough for this game that
was super fun I had a great time with
that one alright so this game is super
fun and unintentionally hilarious for
absolutely intentionally Larry's I
highly recommend it I'll put a link in
the description below I believe it was
free I'm pretty sure but obviously it
runs like a potato so if you have a
potato computer it's like what what my
luck my character duh oh there I go okay
alright see ya so thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want to play
this game for yourself it's down in the
description below
let me know what you thinking if you
want to see more games like this let me
know in the comments as well thanks
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]